what's going on guys this is Rob and I
figured if I want to start doing face
cams I should probably make myself look
presentable as opposed to just looking
like a woolly beast disheveled and
scraggly looking mustache and a beard
and so on and so forth so I've shaved
and all that kind of good stuff
and as you guys notice I've made some
changes to the layout a lot of you guys
said that it was kind of difficult for
you to see what it was that I was
talking about when you were on your
mobile phone and so of you guys really
thought the idea of having links at the
bottom we're just kind of pointless so I
went ahead and just switch things up
change things up and things are pretty
obvious at this point but what you'll
also find here is that the suggested
video will pop up and then it will stay
until the next suggested video pops up
that way you guys will have plenty of
time to decide whether or not the video
that I've suggested is something that
you might want to check out or something
like that so what we're going to be
doing in this video is we're going to be
focusing on the whole fifty thousand
years into the future original send
portion of the Avengers a lot of you
guys had a lot of questions about this a
lot of you guys wanted to know what in
the world was going on with the time Jim
sending Captain America and his handful
of the Avengers into the future and and
what that all meant one thing to keep in
mind is that again what we're going to
find here in this video is that it seems
as though some of the worlds that we're
going to see are going to be part of
secret Wars that is to say we're kind of
getting a preview here but we don't know
this for a fact so I wouldn't swear to
it
but what happens the way the story
initially kicks off and again I'll have
a reading list down below but I'll also
have the the actual comics listed here
in the video is that Captain America
after having been exposed to the
memories of The Watcher as we discussed
on the previous video recalls the entire
thing of the incursions having his mind
wiped and being banished from the
Avengers I'm sorry the Illuminati and so
what he does here is he effectively
brings together a group of Avengers he
brings together Hawkeye Thor Hyperion
star Brant who we haven't talked about
yet as well as Hyperion we need to do a
video about him and I guess a couple of
the characters but basically he brings
them together for the purpose of
confronting Tony Stark and so what
happens here is that when they meet with
Tony Stark immediately Captain America
starts tearing into him basically saying
that he remembers everything that he
knows what it is the Illuminati you're
doing and it has to come to an end and
so in response to the kind of I guess
accusatory tone and a
the I guess presumed violence the
Captain America intends to impose on
Tony Stark Tony Stark activates a
multitude of artificial Tony Stark
robots of Ironman robots and so what
happens is they immediately engage in
combat with with the Avengers and so
basically we have Iron Man and his his
AI robots versus the Avengers but what
happens is that in the midst of this
conflict the time Jim suddenly reforms
now we don't know how it was this
happened we don't really even know why
or at least as far as I've been able to
tell we're really not given a reason why
it's simply just there and what happens
as it Yanks them forty eight years into
the future now when they go 48 years out
of the future the encounter was called
The Avengers Union and what this is is
effectively a new version of The
Avengers these are people who have taken
over the role of being Avengers due to
the fact that the other Avengers have
aged or had been killed star brand for
example had been killed and he had
simply passed his powers on to another
person but Hawkeye is older here but
Hawkeye is really kind of a kicker here
the reason being because as far as he
explains it to us this is the furthest
he ever made it indicating that what had
happened was that this is this has
happened before this is something that's
taken place before there's basically a
paradox of sorts and so what he does is
he immediately attacks Tony Stark and
the reason why he attacks Tony Stark is
because as he describes it Tony Stark
had basically engaged in a set of
actions that led to a multitude of
people dying now what seems to happen
here or at least what we can really kind
of infer here again a lot of this stuff
really isn't answered is that when this
initial trip to the future had taken
place before that Tony Stark had stayed
with the group he had travelled forward
into the future with the group and when
he did he had left the Illuminati behind
and as a result presumably there was an
incursion on earth-616 the rest of the
Illuminati weren't able to stop it
without Tony Stark and so the result was
that that planet Earth was destroyed but
again we don't know because this earth
is here right now so we don't know this
is an alternate reality or at least we
don't know that yet we'll actually find
that out once we see I guess suppose we
get involved with Franklin Richards and
the whole futuristic thing but
nonetheless and what a Hawkeye also does
here is he whispers something to Captain
America and we don't exactly know what
this is we really won't find out until
the end of this story what it was that
he had said to Captain America but what
happens is that the the time Jim reform
now this usually takes place about every
15 or 20 minutes after the arrival of
this group to a new time and so what
they ask Hawkeye is where it is they're
going next and Hawkeye says he doesn't
know this is the furthest that he's made
it and so once the group is yanked into
the future they end up 422 years into
the future now when they end up 422
years of the future what we also find is
that Hawkeye as part of the Avengers the
younger version is basically dissolved
he seems to age extremely fast into a
skeleton and presumably die we're not a
hundred percent sure about that or at
least again we won't find out until the
end of this but what happens here is the
remaining group of the Avengers Hyperion
Thor Black Widow and Captain America and
star brand they basically are I guess
isolated to a cube of source when they
land on this future they're stuck in a
box but what we also do is we see that
Hyperion senses some changes in the Sun
and Thor senses I guess growth in the
Tree of Life to basically indicate how
much time has passed and so they
hypothesized somewhere around 400 years
but then we also see they encounter some
robotic versions of themselves some
robotic versions of Avengers who look
different and were designed to look that
way and the reason why is because as
Thor which is the only actual non
robotic member of the Avengers in this
future as he explains to us at some
point in the past
Ultron basically took over the role of
being the all-father he basically
replaced Odin this planet is basically
Planet Ultron Ultron runs this planet at
some point in the past he had taken over
humanity he had basically emerged from
the from the center of the earth and he
had launched an invading army and so all
that's really left here are around 30
million people who have basically taken
to hiding in refuges who live in I guess
different bunkers or basically in safe
havens and that everybody else who was
on the planet Earth had fled to the
stars they had left the planet entirely
and so what we find is that a bomb or
some kind of device is implanted in the
eye of Captain America and then the time
Jim appears and Yanks them into the
future yet again now when we arrive into
the future for the third time we end up
5,000 years into the future or at least
as a perception that's given to us by
Captain America I think it's actually
around 4000 years or something along
those lines I can't read the exact
number here
but what happens is they meet with
Franklin Richards in addition to this we
also find that Hyperion and Thor have
basically vanished they vanished in the
same way that Hawkeye had vanished and
so as a result we're basically in the
situation whereby Captain America star
brand and Black Widow are the only ones
there to speak with Franklin Richards
now the immediate question that
everybody has is how can Franklin
Richards be alive if it's 4,000 some odd
years in the future why is he here and
he says the reason he's here is because
he can't die because he's effectively
immortal in addition to this he begins
to take Captain America and Black Widow
and star brand on this tour of source of
the world around them or I guess the
universe oh I'm sorry the solar system
around them and what we learned is that
5,000 years into the future that the
planet Ultron is basically gone now that
instead humans and androids are living
in harmony with one another this is
basically ushered an this uncharted era
of peace something that's never been
seen before and that working together
humanity and androids have basically
begun to implement this sort of single
society that is to say a society whereby
you have this merging of humans and
androids into this sort of hybrid which
will eventually begin to take form later
on and I guess come to its fruition
later on but we also find here is that
there's basically in Avengers world this
is an I guess a base of operations the
size of a planet maybe a little bit
bigger that is a kind of multiversal
Guardian group now the question the
Captain America asks Franklin Richards
is how is it that this world exists in
the first place how is this universe
here if it's 5,000 years in the future
and universes are being destroyed left
and right due to the incursions and what
Franklin Richards says is that the
multiverse that universes will evolve
and so this seems to be Franklin
Richards telling us that this is what
one of the worlds will look like after
Secret Wars ends when we're basically in
the new Secret Wars universe but again
as far as I know Hickman hasn't really
come out and said this is the case this
is really something that we just kind of
have to infer from the information
that's given to us but in addition to
this what Franklin Richards does is
begin giving Captain America answers and
one of the questions that Captain
America has or I guess one of the
questions is offered to him by Franklin
Richards is what the source of the
incursions is about why the incursions
happen in the first place captain
it turns down this line of questioning
and it said instead he says he wants to
know how to stop the Illuminati and
Franklin Richards says that's not going
to happen there's no way to stop the
Illuminati and there's no way to stop
the incursions it's inevitable that it's
going to happen and so ultimately what
we find is that the time Jim reappears
once again and basically Yanks everybody
into the future for a fourth time but
one of the other really cool things here
is we learned that this sort of platform
is sort of ship they've been riding on
the whole time had this massive tree and
this massive tree is actually an evolved
version of Groot that's 5,000 years old
or 5,000 years older from the way that
we had last seen them kind of a I guess
a little bit of comedy that was thrown
in there by by Jonathan Hickman but
nonetheless and what we find is at the
fourth time the group travels into the
future they actually get yanked about
50,000 years but the difference here is
that everybody except for Captain
America ends up being dropped off they
end up I guess transitioning or
dissolving or aging or what-have-you and
so Captain America's the only one to
actually see what the world looks like
50 or 51 thousand years in the future
then what happens is he initially
emerges in this world of darkness
there's really nothing there they
haven't he has no idea what's going on
but this path actually lights before him
and he starts to follow this path and
then ultimately comes across what
appears to be this massive obelisk of
sorts and this obelisk kind of lights up
and then he's basically greeted by a
artificial intelligence and what this
artificial intelligence tells him is
that when planet Ultron had basically
been eradicated when planet Ultron's
time had passed that this single seed of
artificial intelligence had survived and
basically began to kind of grow began to
kind of evolve on its own and so
somewhere between the 422 years that we
had seen and the Year 51 thousand that
this artificial intelligence basically
began to manifest itself and that as a
result in the current time frame there
are no humans there's simply artificial
intelligence and that's it anybody who
was human is merged and what's called
the world core and so what happens is
they immediately begin to try to set
about taking Captain America's
consciousness and adopting it into the
world core but then we also see that
this bomb that was planted inside
Captain America emerges and then corrupt
the world core and so as a result it
seems as though this future is basically
Eradicator this version of planet Earth
it doesn't exist anymore now this is
kind of one of the downsides of this
whole time travel thing because we don't
know what the universe looks like
outside of this planet Earth we don't
know what other teams look like outside
of these versions of the Avengers that
we've seen this is pretty much it this
is really all we get and so as a result
Captain America travels into the future
one last time and he basically reaches
the end of time he reaches what appears
to be the end of all things he
encounters iron lad he encounters a
immortus and so on but ultimately with
these three people who are looking upon
Captain America the idea here is that if
time is going to come to an end they
would rather mold it in a way that
benefits them and so what they do is
they encase the time gem inside of a I
guess an element of non time meaning
that the time Jim can't function and so
ultimately Captain America seems to be
stuck in this future in addition they
say they intend to keep him here the
reason being because as far as their
calculations have told them allowing the
Illuminati to go through and try to end
worlds to stop the incursions is the
best course of action and so as a result
they intend to keep Captain America
there and so Captain America effectively
breaks free of the hold from immortus
and iron lad and so on and as a result
he basically jumps back into the past or
sent back into the past using the time
Jim and so what happens here is he
basically recalls what it was that
Hawkeye had told him during their first
trip into the future and what Hawkeye
has said is that he basically had a
handful of options the first option was
that he could help Tony Stark I guess in
the encourages he could help him destroy
the worlds the second thing is he could
do nothing but the third thing he could
do was kill Tony Stark and so this is
the plan that Captain America has and
this is why once original sin was over
we suddenly jumped into the Avengers
when they were hunting down the
Illuminati this is why all that stuff
began to form so I hope that made sense
to you guys time is when Jonathan
Hickman might stories about time it can
be oh man it could be really really
confusing but the stories are really
really cool in terms of the
individuality of each reality that we
come across and so on and so forth so I
hope that made sense to you guys if it
did let me know and again give me some
feedback and what you guys think about
this new layout and and yeah so I will
catch you guys later peace
you